select the piecewise function whose
graph is shown below and or i guess we
should say to the right i copied and
pasted it so it's on the right now so we
have this piecewise continuous function
so it's not defined for
x being negative 2 or lower but then
starting at x greater than negative two
it starts being defined it's continuous
all the way until we get to the point x
equals two and then we have a
discontinuity and then it starts getting
defined again down here and then it is
continuous for a little while all the
way and then after x is
greater than sit when x is greater than
6 it's once again undefined so let's
think about which of these functions
describe this one over here so this one
looks like a
a radical
function shifted so square root of let's
see square root of
x would look something like
square root of x would look like this
let me do it in a color that you could
see
square root of x would look like this
square root of
so square root of x looks like this and
this just looks like square root of x
shifted 2 to the left so this looks like
square root of x plus 2.
this one right over here looks like
square root of x plus 2
and you could verify that when x is
negative 2 negative 2 plus 2 square root
of that is going to be 0. and it's it's
not defined there but we see that if we
were to continue it would have been
defined there but let's try some other
points when x is negative one
negative one plus two is one principal
root of one is one
let's try two when x is equal to two two
plus two is four principle root of four
is positive two so this this looks like
a pretty good candidate so it looks like
our function
so let's see let's see it looks like our
function
would be and i'm not going to call it
anything because it could be p h g or f
but our function
if i were to write it out it looks like
over this first interval so it looks
like it's the square root of
x plus 2 for
negative 2 being less than x it's not
defined at negative 2 but as long as x
is greater than negative 2 and x is less
than or equal to 2 and x is less than or
equal to 2. so that's this part
this part of the function and then it
jumps down
and now this looks like x to the third x
to the third looks something like this
so x to the third power looks something
something like
that
so let's see negative two to the third
power is negative eight
so it looks something like that that's
what x to the third looks like
so two to the third power is eight
two to the third power is eight so x to
the third looks something like that this
looks like x to the third shifted over
four
so i would i'm i'm guessing that this is
x minus four to the third power and but
we can verify that when x is equal to
four four minus four to third power we
do indeed get the value of this
expression being equal to zero when x is
six six minus two to six minus four is
two to the third power is indeed eight
when x is two two minus two two minus
four is negative two to the third power
is indeed negative eight so this over
this over this interval it is x minus
four to the third power so we could say
we could say so this part of the
function
this part of the function
right over here we could say is x minus
to the third power
for x
for x being
so for x being greater than 2 or we
could say 2 is less than
x and it's defined all the way to s x
being equal to 6 but not being greater
than so x is less than or equal to 6. so
which of these choices are what we just
put in so square root of x plus 2 well
that's not c squared of x plus 2 for
negative 2 is less than x is less than
or equal to 2 x minus 4 to the third 4 2
is less than x which is less than or
equal to 6. so i would go
with that one